[Music]
my co-author our peony and I noticed
what we thought was a pattern that every
time there was some great disaster or
catastrophe there was usually an
investigation after the fact what went
wrong and that investigation almost
always revealed that there was some
person before the disaster occurred who
said it was going to occur that person
was always an expert they always had
data that was telling them that there
was going to be something happening but
that person was an outlier they were an
expert but the other experts disagreed
and we wondered is this a phenomenon
that occurs with some regularity because
if there are people who can see
disasters coming before the rest of us
if we could find them before the
disaster that would be enormous ly
valuable if we could find them and
listen to them and pay attention if we
could tell the difference between
Chicken Little and the Cassandra
Cassandra
in Greek mythology was a woman cursed by
the gods the curse was that she could
accurately see the future doesn't sound
so bad until you realize the second part
of the curse which was no one would ever
believe her and because she could see
the future and no one was paying
attention to her she went mad
so the Cassandra's that we looked for
were people who accurately predicted
some future disaster not people who woke
up in the middle of the night with the
premonition not people who predicted all
the time and once in a while get right
but people who saw a specific thing
coming people who had what we call
Sentinel intelligence the ability to see
something over the hill before other
people see it and we found that pattern
and in the first half of the book we go
through seven case studies of past
events where we found Cassandra's were
right and we tried to learn something
about those seven Cassandra's from
passed in the second half of the book we
look at seven people today who might be
Cassandra's who are predicting things
that might happen in the future so we
talk about a failed warning as a
Cassandra event and we tried to ask
ourselves in the book why did this
Cassandra event happen we find that
there are four overall factors there is
the quality of the Cassandra herself or
himself there were there are several
things about that person that make them
a Cassandra or not and then there's the
audience a decision-maker
a king a president CEO there are
qualities about them that contribute to
an event becoming a Cassandra event then
there's the issue itself and the
qualities about the issue that make a
warning relevant to it hard for people
to accept and the last is the critics
the critics of the person giving the
warning the critics of the Cassandra
what do they say and what do they not
say and in those four column heading the
Cassandra the decision-maker
the issue itself and the critics under
each of them there are several different
criteria applying that template to a
potential Cassandra event we think we
can begin to tell who's right and who's
Chicken Little
so in the book we look at a number of
different fields we look at biology
astronomy civil engineering computer
science but we also look at foreign
policy and economics and one of the
foreign policy issues we look at in the
first half of the book was the rise of
Isis we found a Cassandra in the person
of Robert Ford Robert Ford is a career
foreign service officer and a career
Arabist
that means for the United States Foreign
Service the State Department
he's lived and worked for decades in
countries in the Middle East he speaks
Arabic like a native in the number of
different dialects he can walk onto the
street of almost any Arab city and go
into any souk and hear what the locals
are saying and have a dialogue with them
he became our ambassador to Damascus
before the Civil War broke out there and
when he got there just as the Arab
Spring was percolating in other
countries Robert Ford began to realize
that there was a vacuum that unless the
United States stepped in and helped the
opposition to President Assad in
Damascus that somebody else would and
that somebody else he posited would be a
new terrorist organization that it would
rise up not only in Syria against
President Assad as part of the Arab
Spring but it would also rise up in Iraq
where the Shia government was making it
very difficult for the Sunnis in Iraq
and so what Robert Ford said would
happen would be that for the first time
in history terrorists would own a large
chunk of territory he chunk of territory
bigger than many nations and that in
that territory would be very large
cities cities of over a million people
in population and he therefore urged
President Obama to do something to head
this off have the United States filled
the vacuum by giving serious amounts of
training and equipment to the Opposition
in Syria and he wasn't listened to in
part he wasn't listened to because his
prediction was outlandish the creation
of a terrorist state with controlling
cities that had never happened this is
one of the things we find over and over
again that our cassandra's are rejected
because there
things that had never happened before we
call it first occurrence syndrome no
terrorist group had ever built a country
run cities and therefore implicitly
decision makers in Washington thought
he's exaggerating he's being hyperbolic
this can't possibly happen why because
it did never happen before now we know
that throughout history things happen
for the first time things that have
never happened before are what we study
in history in the old days and we
remember dates in history 1492 1066 1776
these were all dates when things
happened of significance that it never
happened before so decision-makers ought
to know that just because something
hasn't happened before it doesn't mean
it won't but implicitly decision-makers
hearing Robert Ford and thinking about
things that have never happened before
they think they have good justification
for ignoring a prediction if it's a
prediction of an initial occurrence
syndrome and then there's the problem of
all the other experts when Ford's
analysis was shared with trusted Middle
Eastern allies like Israel like Jordan
people who have expertise in the Middle
East like the British and the Germans
they all didn't see it like so many of
our Cassandras ambassador Robert Ford
saw something first and in the amount of
time it took for everybody to catch up
with him it was too late by the time the
experts saw what he saw Isis had come
into existence and had taken over large
cities and had created a nation-state
the same phenomenon that we saw with
Robert Ford applied to people involved
prior to Katrina in predicting that the
dams in New Orleans
bursts someday if there were a category
four or five hurricane because the
Cassandra we found in New Orleans was
fired for making a prediction that the
city would flood in the case of
Fukushima in Japan four nuclear reactors
melted down and contaminated a huge
swath of territory and cost the Japanese
government billions of dollars but yet
before those plants were built there was
someone who said if you build it here
there will be a tsunami someday and the
plants will be destroyed and meltdown
and that person testified in open
hearings and was ignored so we found in
many many cases all of these Cassandra's
said the same thing they said I don't
want this to happen I don't want to be
accurate I want to be proven wrong here
is my data tell me what's wrong with my
data and no one could
[Music]
you